kevin monzón se define como un activista
digital es reconocido por sus sátiras
contra el gobierno de daniel ortega en
la red social peak toc
los tres arrestos pues ha sido terrible
para mí porque te puedo decir que me han
golpeado y también de igual manera me ha
amenazado directamente que me van a
matar que van a andar a el chipote
nuevamente que me calle que nos siga
viendo y todas esas cosas me dicen ellos
el joven docter afirma que no teme
a las constantes amenazas y asedio de
parte de afines al gobierno con una
restricción general a protestar en las
calles las redes sociales se han
convertido en una ventana para mostrar
su descontento
exactamente falla donde ellos me
detuvieron y me pidieron por el nombre
completo bueno está bien perfecto vídeo
pero no me van a callar dónde vives te
estoy detenido a través de unas celdas
aguantando miles de cosas pero yo voy a
seguir siempre resistencia defensores de
derechos humanos temen nuevos arrestos
con la aprobación el año pasado de una
ley de ciberdelitos que según el
gobierno pretende proteger a los
usuarios de redes sociales existen
demasiado
y delitos cibernéticos que efectivamente
no tienen los suficientes argumentos
legales desde el código penal para poder
sancionarlos sin embargo lo que estamos
observando desde que esto es una pauta o
un arma que puede utilizar el gobierno
para seguir restringiendo sean
censurando lo que son las personas que
no están de acuerdo por razones
políticas si te puedo decir pues esta
ley quiere venir a callar el periodismo
quiere venir a callar a la gente que
esté informando quiere venir a callar al
pueblo porque está express está en las
redes sociales y por eso esa ley el
próximo mes de noviembre nicaragua
tendrá elecciones generales en un
ambiente muy polarizado por ahora este
tipo que juega a su libertad al subir un
nuevo vídeo